Hi, I hope you have a lot of water
lying around because between mine and Ryan's
talk, we are going to have a lot of "node"
among other things — mentioned.
This is merge conflict and management development
for developers.
I'm at Samsung Next.
By day and other hours I'm working on Node
in the community and a cat-herder of conferences.
You can find me on GitHub and Twitter, and
the far corners of the internet as @hackygolucky
Thanks for being here and listening for me
for a few minutes about some of this stuff.
A disclaimer: I'm not a licensed psychotherapist.
My undergraduate education was a bachelor
of science degree in psychology and sociology,
but what that mostly means is I spent four
years trying to diagnose myself with some
disorder.
I'm frame of mind trained in crisis counselling
as well as peer mediation conflict management,
and had experience in practising that, but
this talk is not a substitution for going
and getting trained yourself and being supervised
by licensed experts to teach you how to execute
on some of these lessons.
As the education manage of Node, and now on
the moderation team, I'm leading the conflict
management tree-shake programme for Node leadership
and collaborators, the folk who keep the project
ticking for millions of users.
We will walk through applying that to open-source
developers distributed across the globe and
removing barriers to stability by improving
productivity with healthy collaboration as
peer conflict management.
So back when programmers were running tests
and prepping for the Y2K bug and GDPR was
a millennial lifetime away, my middle school
leaders found themselves at an impasse with
a pretty impossible challenge on their hands.
Tons of fights and lots of physical violence
was going on.
I went to a public school.
Students were pouring into the guidance counsellor
with, what seemed to the adults, to be small
arguments mostly fuelled by puberty.
Along dismissing those problems, they finally
agreed to bring in an experiment, a peer mediate
programme.
Every student in the school was required to
take the training.
A room, a space for the peer mediation, was
dedicated.
A teacher was only in there to sit and watch
and stay quiet before the peers, we were required
to visit and volunteer in the peer peer mediation
classroom once a week as if it was a study
hall.
The teachers and guidance counsellors were
no longer breaking up the fights.
They trusted the students to solve their problems,
how to communicate what they're feeling, why
they're feeling and, and to be calmly dialogue
about their disagreements and the occurrences
of fighting dropped dramatically.
So, someone you relate to, going through the
same history quizzes and algebra exams, they
don't look or act like you but they have to
make it to the other side like you.
Something hiding on the other surface of the
story is we don't wake up having these tools
to facilitate conflict naturally, it has to
be cultivated by kid or as adults.
This is a gift given to me by the secondary
education, and I thought it might translate
to our distributed online world if done with
wear.
We're programmers and also human.
I get very, very fired up in debates.
It feels good, if only temporary, to think
that you're right.
When you've taken it too far, though, built
up this idea of another person on the other
side of the screen who is doing something
so intentionally malicious, you're talking
past each other.
There's no understanding motivations.
The words on your screen are the surface layer
of what is going on.
So what is conflict?
Conflict gets a really bad rap but that's
a bit unfair.
It's not inherently bad.
Modern theories consider conflict a natural
and inevitable outcome of human interaction.
Conflict situations also often lead to the
generation of new ideas and positive change.
So, that's a lot to unpack.
Let's talk some approaches that we can use
as instruments to put in our tool boxes to
communicate a little more kindly in our everyday
work.
So the work we've done thus far with the Node
moderation team has, through honing governance
and taking a deep look at what we need to
change to modify behaviour, incidentally mirrored
when a Nobel Prize winning economist spoke
of evidence-based social design.
Limit effects of bad behaviour, and that is
through moderation systems, making inappropriate
posts less prominent, keeping consistent moderation
policies, including community members in the
moderation, offering reversion tools and introducing
filters.
Limit bad behaviour itself.
You can do that through activity quotas, temporary
or permanent bans, and consistent criteria
for the bans outlined with process.
Encourage volunteering and compliance by ensuring
people learn the norms, showing examples of
appropriate or inappropriate behaviour but
not too often and dwelling on it, displaying
statistics on the normative behaviour, and
reminding people about the norms at the point
of action.
So with the advent of social coding through
GitHub, online communities have broken down
physical location differences in communication
barriers, creating a new challenge with folks
who are not employed by the same company but
collaborating on a common goal.
The speed at which we pass both positive and
negative information, it is a break neck pace.
Even if we were to be at the same company,
a well-meaning manager, a very well-staffed
HR firm, or internal team, they would have
a hard time-keeping up.
So, with volunteer contributes, as is much
of the the way of many open-source projects,
attention and time are a limited resource.
Low-quality contributions such as commenting
without seeking out some context prior, creates
a social dilemma.
These contributions drown out other contributions
with time and emotional labour, and often
exhaust the available attention.
So conflict researchers have studied this,
and the effects on code source software development
is easier to track.
Dr Steve Sawyer surveyed 40 package software
development teams and concluded how people
work together and mitigate conflict is more
important than the individual skills and ability
of the team's members in predicting their
software developer performance.
So, — yes.
[Applause].
What do you think Node project activity looks
like when we've ended up in big fights on
Twitter, or on long essays of debates going
back and forth on GitHub long derailed the
issue at hand?
PRs and pushes dropped to a drawl when comments
shoot up.
So, we are makers, and there's no doubt we
love to fix things, and we are paid to problem-solve.
But we can't fix them all, and we can certainly
not do all of this good work alone.
But we try through trial and error in iterating
over governance, moderation policies, and
codes of conducts, and in value consensus.
So, as moderators in open source, we lay the
ground work for participants to understand
one another's perspectives.
For a content management system to work, we
had to establish that proper grounding first.
We don't have to agree to get along, but a
common understanding and a value system context
is important to effective interaction.
So, last year, the first thing that we did
was meet as the top-level project committees,
and reran a core values session at collaboration
summit.
Even with its global impact, Node had relied
on an implicit understanding of community
members' expectations.
Core values serve as the boundaries within
which an organisation will operate in pursuit
of its vision.
Moving forward, we codify expectations so
we can work effectively together and empower
members in the best interests of a global
Node.
It is vital that we address good behaviour
practices, so we created the member expectations
file.
It is important that members of our leadership
group, that was the TSE community committee,
also the members of the board, act in a way
that not only complies with the code but that
models the vision, mission, and operating
principles of the Node project that we are
seeking.
Cultural acceptance: so cultural elements
underline conflict are really important considerations
we need to bear in mind.
Adding an extra edge and degree of sensitivity
to the difficult tasks of mediation and peace-building.
This includes perception-checking, how our
own perception is affecting the conflict we
are part of, and what influences our mental
programming has on how we are proceeding.
Creative ways of handling conflicts emerges
from the adoption of a flexible outlook.
In short, one size does not fit all.
A nuanced approach to conflict through list
he can first, gaining contacts from parties,
proceeding with care in the spaces, with which
the parties feel comfortable, often allow
for early resolve instead of continued management.
The tooling: so, I would be remiss not to
dive in a bit to the cooling constrains that
we as open-source moderators of conflict have.
Where do your communities live?
For Node, we live on GitHub, we live on Twitter,
we, in fact, for some time, had a magnitude
more tweets than the next most active programme
language, Java.
I'm not kidding, or being hyperbolic.
Node has grown up with GitHub.
We felt the pain of what it means to limit
permissions of contributors for security's
sake, and then moderators don't have access
to act swiftly or ban bad actors.
We've celebrated the awesome work they've
done in recent years with incredible features
giving the power to maintainers to better
fine-tune permissions, reduce noise, and ensure
productive through user-blocking and apply
community guidelines through a repo.
And then there is scope.
We had to take a step back and look at what
spaces our ecosystem interacts in but also
what we have control over.
We can work to improve the environment in
GitHub because we control that space.
We have the permissions and the administrative
tools do do that.
What about Twitter?
Or Reddit, or Hacker News.
We chose a strategy of the scope we could
commit to, so as GitHub, select Slack and
IRC groups, and event.
That can be tough when many of us have found
sub committees in these spaces that are really
helpful but we spend a lot of time trying
to help in these spaces and we've ended up
with over exposed and attacked community members.
So the who.
The Node moderation team.
We have an elevated responsibility to observe
patterns, audit processes and draft new governance
to improve our work spaces of the Node project.
The top-level committees, the TSC, the technical
steering committee, and the community committee,
are voting members who jointly select or object
to any person on the moderation team.
And the process verifies the shared trust
contributors have who are ending up selected.
So let's be clear, though, as I move through
these examples.
As I've said already, perspective is vital
to being effective in these challenges, and
we still lack in diversity on the moderation
team.
I think that's echoed through much of the
Node project, which also means we have gaps
in time zone coverage.
We will never be as effective as a group when
the make-up of our team doesn't mirror the
make-up of the environment community we would
like to see in Node.
This is an uphill battle worth fighting.
As moderators, we respect that maintaining
trust is key to being effective.
In conflict management, we get to be the bridge-builders
—
we remove conflict barriers as facilitators
of conversations, so now that we've got the
who, what, and why, let's how.
So, anyone that wants to request moderation
can do so.
They do have to be a member of our organisation.
Requesting moderation of a post can be accomplished
in one of four ways.
The first is to mail to report at node.js.org.
A second is a private email to our members
listed in our readme with their email and
full contact information.
You can also file an issue in the same — a
new post in the same thread as the post with
the moderation request.
We can also request moderation via a new issue
in Node.js moderation repo.
Collaborators can collaborate non-collaborator
posts at any time without submitting a request.
Or getting a request by someone else.
So this is because, while we have a moderation
team, anyone with a collaborator status is
helping contribute to the values expressed
through repeated interactions with participants.
The moderation team helps set policy and modelling
but all collaborators can and will moderate,
or can and moderate by default.
We're going to talk a little later about how
we are working to the intention al and better
prepare the collaborators for all this.
When a request is sent by email to report
at node.js.org or directly to a moderate team
member, a new issue detailing that request
has to be logged in Node.js/moderation.
The identity of the individual submitting
the request is omitted from the issue unless
the — when you're having a conflict with
a co-co-worker, does your manager or HR sit
you down in an open office or talk to you
about it?
No.
They take you into a private secretary where
you feel comfortable to talk candidly and
gain perspective without feeling judged, or
feeling judged but that is easier to swallow
in private.
The moderation repo is a private repo, but
everyone who is a collaborate or has permission
to view and interact on these threads.
Hundreds of folks.
We do this so folks are able to offer help,
insight, and context.
By reducing the scope of exposure when dealing
with these issues filed, we are also avoiding
the drive-byes.
Scope and audience are vital to managing what
is within your control of change, and what
requires tackling from multiple dependencies
or groups to effect change on the scale that
is required.
A great example of this is when momentum builds
off a Reddit post.
When a harassing post is made on Reddit, if
it is reported to us and we don't have the
bandwidth to alert on everything that is happening
in Node trolling on the internet, we will
try to address it.
We learned the hard way with this one, though.
We can reach out to moderators of node Reddit
as an example for them to rectify but we can't
force them to do anything.
We can look to see if the harassers are current
contributors to the project and sanction them.
We can make a public statement to reiterate
what we do and do not do tolerate as behaviour,
but what we can do if it is someone not invested
in the project, does not operate in our spaces,
so banning doesn't punish them, what do we
do with this drive-by harassment?
We give them no platform.
Because they are trolls, and they are curbies
of negative energy, and they will be empowered
by us responding.
We log the users and look for future activity
in the project if they ever engage and try
to bring that toxicity.
Thanks to these experiences as moderators,
we established that requests for moderation
that do not appear to have been submitted
in good faith with the intent to address a
legitimate code of conduct violation, we will
ignore it.
It turns out some folks will try to manipulate
your moderators to use them as an attack vector
for their harassment targets.
So, before moderating a post, collaborators
and moderation teams specifically consider
the possible intent of the author, as I've
just said, and we especially try to assume
folks are acting in good faith.
I mentioned trolls before but we do not operate
under the assumption on first look that anyone
is a troll.
It's possible that the author is simply made
has error or is not yet familiar with the
code of conduct.
It may be that cultural differences exist
or that the author is unaware that certain
content is considered inappropriate.
And in these cases, we make no assumption
of malintent and give the author an opportunity
to correct any error that may have been made.
But unfamiliarity or mis interpretations of
the conduct does not excuse a post for moderation.
Moderation and team members will exclude or
block an individual from the node GitHub-org.
Identifying the GitHub account beak acted
upon must be posted to this moderation repo
for all collaborators to see with an explanation
provided by us on the moderation team.
Any individual blocked from the node GitHub
org will be recommended for exclusion from
any node foundation event as well.
If the author of the reporting posting disagrees
that moderation is required, such as they
won't edit or retract what they've been asked
to, the matter can be escalated to the method
race team as well if the other collaborate
resource' requests haven't been met.
Moderation action — no moderation act should
be take until a decision by the moderation
team is made.
I will explain in a little bit about why we
do that and don't let a single individual
make that call.
Trusted folks: these are the collaborators,
folks who are active in engaging in the project.
When the post is authored by another collaborator
for an issue of potential violation, as a
moderator, I must explain the justification
for moderating the post, identify all changes
made to the post, identify the steps previously
taken to resolve the issue.
If the moderation action included blocking,
as I said before, we have to make sure and
file an issue that demonstrates the justification
for the action.
Explanations of moderation actions on collaborator
posts must be provided in, and a new post
within the original thread, a new issue within
the Node.js moderation repo, and any collaborator
habitually violating the code of conduct,
or this moderation policy, may be blocked
temporarily, or in extreme cases removed and
blocked indefinitely.
We don't have a three strikes and you're out
because that's not sensitive enough for the
levels of interpretation that we need.
So we spend time documenting this activity
for educational purposes and reinforcement
of values.
We don't want to scare good humans away from
making a mistake.
Repeated mistakes with no record of listening
or learning is another story.
Separately, there are a lot of folks who don't
hop in threads but observing the modelling,
logging actions and requirements hold us accountable
for consistency so moderators reduce their
likelihood of being partial.
This is vital for the advocacy working together
day-to-day and most important for those in
the leadership of the context.
Unknown folks: these are participants who
have not yet established themselves as repeated
contributors to the project.
When a post is authored by another — when
is a post is authored by one of them, the
big difference here is that we have to dig
up any history that we can find on interactions
with these folks, because we don't have a
history, it is much harder for us to go and
interpret, so oftentimes, it's reaching out
to the individual any way we can to talk to
them privately.
And then, also consulting with other members
of the moderation team to see if there is
something that can be done such as he had
indicating.
If they don't respond, in a way that feels
like they are learning, then we know what
we need to do.
But as part of that, because they don't have
access to the collaborators' private moderation
repo, we have then to try and make a decision,
and then make sure to log it in the public
place that this person can see it.
There are circumstances where we won't do
that, though.
Again, no moderator makes thee decisions alone,
and no-one bears the burden of that decision
alone.
Historically moderating leads to retaliation
or escalation of inappropriate behaviour by
the individual whose post is being moderated,
and I should say it can, it doesn't necessarily.
This is the true intent of individuals whose
true intent is to hoar rats, disrupt, or annoy
a member of the community.
In these cases, it's best to handle the moderation
as quickly and quietly as possible without
drawing any further attention.
This reduces the velocity and intensity of
the attacks and protects the teams from emotional
labour exhaustion.
So, interaction limits: one of the cool tools
that GitHub offers us is a cooldown.
So, what we do is take advantage of GitHub's
temporary interaction limits.
We will temporarily limit who can comment,
create pull requests and make issues between
collaborators and contributors.
After 24 hours, the limit expires and the
users go back to participating in the discussion.
And then we move on to temporary and permabans.
A temporary block is time-limited as well.
The time frame is decided on by our team at
the time of issuing, depending on the severity
of the issue.
The recommended defaults for us are 24 hours,
48 hours, and seven days.
An indefinite block is set for an unspecified
amount of time, and may only be lifted for
an individual through a simple majority vote
of the moderation team.
Moderation of posts authored by non-collaborators
may result in these non-collaboratives being
blocked temporarily or indefinitely from further
participation in the org.
In the case where a GitHub account appears
to have been created with no intention to
collaborate in good faith, we will swiftly
act without following the above procedures
including removing posts, blocking indefinitely
and get accounts to GitHub, but that's after
receiving plus-ones from team-mate.
Accounts reasonably believed to be bots are
subject to immediate blocking.
We're pretty conservative on handing out blocks.
Temp blocks we set reminders to revisit the
bans.
These tend to be removed where — I have
not seen in my history permanent bans revisited
and lifted.
I don't know of an instant where we've regretted
the scenarios because we're very cautious
to exercise that in the first place, and multiple
plus-ones including the group they were interacting
with are considered.
So why haven't I rehashed all of the gory
details of our flame wars and ravenous trolls?
For one, it's all still there in issues, and
Twitter, if you would like to waste your be
bi- reading those old ghost stories, but I
don't think it's good to spend energy this
way.
I think it's best to find energy what we've
made mistakes on and fix and then building.
We have rules around this in Node.
Any collaborator found to be violating the
privacy of the node operation repo by sharing
or discussing details of the issues, and any
public forum or social media, risks being
permanently removed from the Node GitHub organisation.
To be removed means you cannot contribution
to Node, the project.
So, collaborators, maintainers, leaders, there
is power in showing off in doing work on a
regular cadence.
Open source, because so many of us volunteer,
words often comes — through ... . The ones
who are trusted most often have the most to
lose, but can also be a win the lottery and
disappear factor for the ecosystem.
What if a person in these legacy groups is
seen as a bad actor?
This goes far beyond the moderation team's
purview.
What if your project doesn't have a way to
address this?
That doesn't mean you can't act, but it means
you need to act with extreme care and intention.
With excellent and consistent communication,
including the folks who have been reported
on.
How many people do you know are good at addressing
elephants in@room?
How about being able to look someone in the
eye that you work with every day and tell
them they need to stop a behaviour that other
groups have been — other people have been
enable willing for years?
Most of us aren't taught these skills.
So what we know in that scenario is that it
leads to a lot of people hurt, lost trust,
and declined productivity.
It takes a long time to recover and instill
lasting changes, so all of this, feeling like
we had a licensing way to go, we called in
the experts.
In searching for a group that would be able
to address our concerns for training, we knew
we would need folks who were trained to train,
and understand our globally distributed set
of individuals.
So, it turns out this isn't as common a domain
you would think in spite of being this large
world we operate in.
We engaged with online peer mediation platform
team, known for building conflict management
programmes in universities and workplace settings.
They had the following credentials: so, the
plan is that the moderation team and leadership,
including the project of the board, are the
first round of trainees.
So, we are going through six modules, this
is an hour and a half per week, and this is
going to include reviewing materials ahead
of time as well as evaluation, discussion,
role playing, and simulations, including GitHub
commenting, and practising with feedback.
And that includes in curriculum, things like
like emotional intelligence, culture and conflict,
and online conflict resolution skills which
are very unique skill set to have, of course.
So then we are going to be rolling that out
to the wider collaborator base, raising the
level of fluency and calmly and effectively
communicating through and beyond conflict
with our collaborators in Node.
It's a very exciting prospect and we're really
grateful to have the resources.
So we have great examples, training, and improving
governance but a final component missing:
self-care.
If you aren't a whole rested person, how do
you build others up?
Moderation and conflict management take a
lot of emotional energy.
Each of us who volunteer on this work have
to carve out time to replenish meaningful
to us.
In the community we talk about this.
In the moderation team, we take care.
That can include therapy, exercise, having
other people who hold you to disengage from
this good work.
We like to think that we are still in the
wild west, and that we are responsible for
coming up with solutions because the answers
don't exist but we don't need to reinvent
the wheel for our human relations problems.
There are whole professions devoted to the
science of making these experiences better.
Great communication begins with connection.
What makes us different from one another is
so much less important that had a what makes
us alike.
We all long for acceptance and significance.
When we recognise those needs in ourselves,
we can better understand them in others, and
[sound distorted].
That's it, thank you.
[Applause].